[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar using chemically defined media
for cell culture
i am kaylee bach of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by fujifilm irvine scientific
to learn more visit irvinesci.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
like to know welcome our speaker
dr sharon shahabi
r indeed manager
cell in gene therapy at fujifilm irvine
scientific
dr shahavi you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone thanks very much for the
nice introduction as it mentioned my
name is sharom shahabi
and i'm rnd manager
in the lmg therapy group at fujifilm
airline scientific
the title of today's presentation
is using chemically defined media for
cell culture
at first
i want to talk about the learning
objectives
of this presentation the learning
objectives objectives will be understand
the potential of chemically defined
serum free cell culture media describe
the benefits of chemically defined media
discussed the scientific concern faced
when cell culturing with serum based
media
and learn how to make the switch from
film based media
to
chemically defined media
and the discussion topics include a
brief in overview of fujifilm irvine
scientific
theorem for cell culture media serum
free and chemically defined media
challenges in developing throne free and
cultural media building a serum free
medium and two cases study
study one is prime x speed and distix
cell maturation cdm and cases 32 is
going to be
prime xv t cell cydia
so at first our mission in our mission
in fujifilm airman scientific
for more than 50 years
our mission has been to develop and
supply products and services for the
growth and
handling of mammalian cells
wherever we can contribute to the health
and well-being of mankind
airline scientific has been leading
innovative projects for more than 50
years at it's shown in this slide this
company started its war in
1970 by producing
uh classical um
media and serums since then this company
has expanded and also innovated several
cell cultural media and reagents
including but not limited to serum free
and chemically defined media
airline scientific was
acquired
by
fujifilm holding in 2018
and was renamed fujifilm irvine
scientific
one of the important in vitro methods
are cell and tissue culture methods that
are generally fast cheap and
reproducible
and also reduce the use of experimental
animals that's very important
to keep cells alive for relatively long
periods of time and to evaluate
proliferation migration and
differentiation
the basal medium must be supplemented
with several factors
serum
from animals
or humans is most commonly used to
maintain ample reflate cells
cell cultural techniques as you know are
used to grow and maintain cells or
various types including those
derived from primary tissues such as
stem cells and also cancer tumors
a major confounding factor
with cell culture is the use of serum or
animal products to supplement media
the most common form
of film supplement are animal based
fetal
bovine from or sps and fetal calcium or
fcs
a disadvantage of
using serum is animal based products
introduce
batch and lot variations
that can lead to experimental
wearability
so in this slide i wanna just briefly
talk about chemically defined medium
that's the main topic of our
presentation today
a chemically defined medium is a growth
medium suitable for the in vitro cell
culture in which all the chemical
components are now
standard cell culture media commonly
consists of a basal medium supplemented
with animal serum such as fps
as a source of nutrients and other
underdefined factors
chemically defined medium
requires that all components be
identified and have
their exact concentrations now
it should be free from any animal or
human derived component
despite the advantage
of adding strong to the cell culture
media
food
cell culture practice or gccp that's an
atom
to develop a common standard for the
cultural method recommends to not use
serum unless it's absolutely
necessary
the implementation of the use of
chemically defined media is part of the
gccp
this will decrease
the dependence on serum that's a
supplement with an undefined and verbal
composition
so
when we consider supplementing cells
and tissue culture media with serum then
no unless principle
should be applied
this principle says
that perfectionally
the medium should not contain any animal
drug component unless it was
proven
to be
an absolute requirement
so before moving forward i want to share
with you some of the definition in this
area i mean strong free and chemically
defined media area
so it's still free component does not
contain serum or plasma so it may
contain components derived from serum or
plasma
this may include animal derived
components such as bovine serum albumin
and other crude
protein fraction
xeno-free
products may contain human derived
components such as
human
from growth factor or insulin but
they don't contain any animal derived
component
animal component free products do not
contain any animal or human dry products
to the tertiary level
it means raw material handling storage
and final product manufacture and also
packaging are
conducted with a dedicated
and animal component free
facility and equipment
all chemical
components in a chemically defined
medium have known composition and
concentrations for example recombinant
proteins
chemically defined medium provides
reproducible results traceability and
regulatory compliance
are some challenges in developing from
free cell culture media
as you know over the last 20 years
investigations into cell functions have
identified components which have been
useful in the development of modern
throne-free cell culture media however
considering the advantages of serum for
cell cultural media there are several
challenges in developing
serum free cell cultural media for
example i can say replacing the
components of serum protective effects
option for example against shear stress
and ph changes
and self-specific requirements
so regarding the components of zero
they for example include proteins for
attachment and career growth factors
hormones
minerals and lipids
other than the advantages
were mentioned in the previous slide
there are other advantages regarding
using throne for cell culture
serum is a complete media it contains
all components
required for cell growth
it increases viscosity so lesser shear
forces arise and viability of cell is
gonna be more and it acts as a buffer so
all of these advantages
they're going to be
challenges against developing serum free
and
chemically defined media
with time
it's been clear
that almost every cell type
has its own requirement
concerning medium supplements
different cell types have different
receptors involved in self-survival
growth and differentiation and they
release
different factors to their environment
therefore
a universal serum free
cell and tissue culture medium may not
be physical
furthermore by increasing the degree of
chemical definition the specificity of
media is increased too
we exclude serum from a cell and tissue
culture medium and still maintains cell
adhesion growth and proliferation it's
important to include a large number of
several components in the cell culture
medium here
a schematic modular approach for the
development of serum free media is shown
as a mediocre
the bottom of the pyramid contains
the basal medium which includes for
example dmem hams
supplemented with the insulin
transferring selenium
or igs
to make
adherent cells stick
to the bottom of
the cell culture of a cell coating with
components
of the extracellular matrix should be
considered
the next except in medial formulation
and development is the addition of the
specific hormones or growth factors
and the type of pyramid represents
increased specificity in strong free
media composition i mean the addition of
lipid antioxidants and
vitamins to show
how chemical defined medial work i will
present two cases studies
as the first case study i will talk
about the primaxy dendritic cell
maturation cdn
that's a chemically defined and animal
component free medium
this medium has been developed for the
in vitro differentiation
of monocytes into a mature dendritic
cell and subsequent maturation to
produce mature dendritic cells
other key attributes of this medium
include achievement of highers of
mature
dendritic cells with the desired
characteristic and functionality
maintains potency of dendritic cells for
t cell stimulation
chemically defined
so it's a chemically defined medium it's
medium so it means that it contains
recombinant albumin but not plus
moderate volume
it's animal component free
and it requires cytokines based on
the end user's application
before moving forward with this case
study i want to show you how this medium
contributes
to dendritic cell immune throughout the
vocabulary you can't see that then there
is six elemental people flowing this
slide
so actually
uh
the monocyte enrichment happens
in
peripheral blood molecular cells of the
patient
so after that
monocytes gonna be differentiated to
natural dendritic cells using
cytokines for example interleukin-4
angular-site macrophage corneal
stimulating factors and then
the immature dendritic cells gonna get
matched
so
then naturally dendritic cells
will be exposed to antigens as they to
be prime and the prime dendritic cells
gonna
be injected back to the patient's body
so
in this area i mean differentiation of
monocytes to a natural dendritic cells
and after that maturation of natural
dendritic cells
this is where
this medium can help
and facilitate the procedure
so the aim of this medium is the
differentiation maturation and
maintenance of monocyte derived diabetic
cells
and also
demonstrate a t helper one polarized
immune response
the performance was measured by
maturation and maintenance of monocyte
drive dendritic cells
total viable cell density was used as a
quantitative measurement of medial
performance we wanted equal
to or even better than benchmarks
that we
we used uh the benchmark were a
commercially available dentist cell
maturation media and also rpm i plus 10
percent fbs
while the other indicators such as cell
surface marker expansion and mixed
lymphocyte reaction they use
as a qualitative measurement
negatively enriched cd14 positive
monocytes from different donors where
culture in either prime
big swedish cell maturation cdn
this group
other commercially available medium
this group
or rpm i plus 10 percent fps that's
disco
for six days the culture was for six
days in the presence of gmcsf and also
intel looking for to induce
differentiation then subsequently
culture
this self
culture for two more days in the
presence of gender alpha interleukin-1
veda and interleukin-6 and also
prostaglandin 2 to induce maturation
for combined culture combined cultural
duration of 8 days
resulting cells were analyzed by
polycytometry to measure viable cell
density
as you can see in this slide the yield
achieved
y prime xv dendritic cell maturation cdn
was comparable with those of the other
commercially available
medium and also rpmi plus 10 percent fps
this slide shows what we expected
regarding the change in the expression
of different surface markers during
differentiation of monocytes to the
natural dendritic cells and then to the
mature dendritic style as you can see
the maximum expression of cd14 happens
on the surface of monocytes whereas its
expression decreases with maturation of
monocytes to a natural dendritic cell
and it becomes zero on the surface of
natural detected itself
on the other hand
we don't expect expression of cd83
and cd 190
on the surface of monocyte their
expression starts from a natural
denderitic cells but it reached to its
maximum level
when the enderitic cells become match
yeah
the minimum expression of cd80 hla dr
and cd 209
would be unmonocyte
and they reach to their maximum
expression at the surface of natural
dendritic cell after explanation of the
expected kinetics of the expression of
the surface marker during maturation of
monocytes to natural disease
let's see what our experiment showed in
this experiment negatively selected
cd14 positive monocytes were cultured in
prime
xv dendritic cell maturation cdn first
they differentiated to a mature
dendritic cell and then the maturation
of emitter dendritic cells to mature
dendritic cells was induced using a
standard to conclude
the results showed surface marker
expression profile at day zero i mean
monocytes day six
immature dendritic cell and day eight
natural dendritic cell
as you can see typical surface
expression provide observe when cultured
in primax feed and refix cell maturation
cities i don't want to go in much
details but it follows
what we expected the other experiment
was about the ability of primaxy
dendritic cell maturation sediment to
generate dendritic cells capable of
inducing t cell for reflection
on day eight monocyte derived dendritic
cells that had been culturing prime
speed and genetic cell maturation cdn
were harvested and co-cultured with
allergenic cd for positive t cells plus
interleukin-246 days prior to analysis
as you can see
t-cell stimulatory capacity was
confirmed by lasso
cfse which was similar between prime
speed and electric cell maturation cdm
this group
rpm i plus 10 percent fps this group and
two other commonly utilized suppliers
these groups
the number of donors
for this experiment there were three
in addition
philosophy analysis demonstrated an
increase in interference gamma
expression
across three different donors compared
to rpm i plus 10 percent
fps and also two other commonly utilized
suppliers so these results indicate that
prime xp dendritic cell
maturation cdm generates dc's
that
they were capable of inducing t helper
one
polarization so
at the conclusion of this study i can
say
primaxy dendritic cell maturation cdm
the chemically defined and animal
component-free formulation is capable of
comparable maintenance of wearable cell
number to the benchmark and other
supplier suppliers tested across
multiple donors
inducing differentiation of monocytes
to immature
dendritic cells and maturation of
immature dendritic cells to mature
dentistic cells
inducing a standard dendritic cell
surface marker expression profile
and inducing t cell proliferation and t
helper one polarization even better
than the benchmark and other suppliers
as the cases study two i will talk about
primax vt cell cdm that launched by
fujifilm irvine scientific as the first
commercially available chemically
defined animal component free medium for
diesel carbs
this medium has been developed to
maximize
consistent growth of t-cell why
maintaining their functionality
and also therapeutic potential
in this slide if i show the cortisol
therapy workflow just because
one of the most applicable most
important application of this medium is
going to be using
therapy
as you can see there are
several steps for example collection
isolation activation modification
expansion
washing and processing and also
administration
to the patient
so this medium can be used in different
steps of cortisol therapy workflow
as i mentioned before an increasingly
important trend in cell cultural media
for immunotherapy is the move away
from animal derived and undefined
components to serum free and chemically
defined cultural conditions
actually when working with t-cells the
advantage of this approach is even more
because animal derived components are
variable between lots and the naturally
occurring cytokines and growth factors
in them can
result in undesirable effects for
example
cytokine and growth factors have been
shown to impact growth
phenotypes and also the potential of t
cells to polarize into therapeutic
subtypes chemically defined media also
reduces
the risk of introducing foreign agents
or impurities from undefined components
thereby
chemically defined media facilitating a
scale-up
to commercial production and the
regulatory submission process
i mentioned a scaling of the t-cell
cultures
bioreactors are very useful tools for
scaling up cell cultures here you can
see
two bioreactor systems
g-rex
that's a static system and quantum
bioreactor that's the dynamic system
there are some benefits for bioreactor
for example
g-rex
but some benefit
it's got
increased oxygenation linear scale up
not feeding required
it depends uh if we
use the m or r series
so it's designed for immune cells
and double amount of the resulting cells
for quantum bioreactors there are other
uh there are some benefits too for
example oxygen oxygenation increase
continuous control of temperature
control flow of liquids control of
metabolites and high cell viability
double amount of resulting cell and also
it's a closed system
however
scaling up from aesthetics and culture
conditions like plates flags are also
directed to dynamic conditions like
quantum bioreactors may result in some
challenges for serum free culture cells
one of the most important challenges is
the increased shear stress as you can
see here
as before mentioned serum itself is the
protector against sheer forces so
this challenge is really important for
serum free cultural media
ceramics
pieces cdm got some key attributes for
example it's designed to support x vivo
rapid t-cell growth and viability
while maintaining functionality of
t-cells
it suffers t-cell expansion from pbmcs
and isolated t-cells
it's validated
to support different t cell subsets it
supports t cell expansion without
additional serum under chemical defined
conditions
it's chemically defined so it means that
it contains recombinant albumin for
example it's animal component free
it requires cytokines based on end user
application
t cell cdm designed specifically for t
cell not for general immune cells unlike
other commercial media
and it's the first commercially
available chemically defined animal
component free medium for this culture
to evaluate the ability of prime xvt
cell cdm to support t-cell expansion in
g-rexes and quantum bioreactor
an experimental study was designed and
performed in fujifilm pairwise
scientific randy cell and gene therapy
group
current slide showed the experimental
setup in gxs and quantum board reactors
as you can see this study was done
on pbmcs and using intelligent2 and
antibodies against cd3 and cd28
the aim of this study was to show that
the prime xvt cell cdn
supports
the t-cell expansion in g-rex system and
also quantum bi-reactor at least as good
as
the available benchmark non-chemically
defined media
as you can see in this slide the cd3
positive
expansion was the same by using three
tested media indirect system i mean
by using prime xv t cell cdm
commercially available
the zeno serum free or xsf
medium
and also rpm i plus 10 percent fps
so you know that
cd3 is a time t cell mark
so
uh
in quantum bioreactor t cell expansion
by using
prime xv t cell cdn
was obviously better than that of
commercially available
excess fm
yeah
regarding the viability of three media
uh
actually as you can see in this slide
those three media have a similar and
acceptable effect in glx system here
in quantum bioreactors the viability of
cells by using prime xv t cells tdm
and commercially available
xsfm was the same however the prime xct
cell cdm
has a better effect
as you can see in this slide cd3
positive fault expansion is a bit a
marked increase
hollow fiber
by reactor i mean quantum bioreactor
versus t-rex
as you can see in this slide
in the g-rex system the expression of
cd25 that's the alpha chain of
interleukin-2 receptor and it's an
activation marker
what's the same
and almost 0
amongst three groups
the expression of cd 6 to 2 62 l or l
selecting and pd one marker that's an
exhaustion marker where also similar
amounts
prime
xp t cell
group commercially
available excess fm
and
also rpm i plus 10 percent fps pro as
you can see here
in the quantum bioreactor
the expression of cd25 was up obviously
more by using
prime xv
t cell cdm and the commercially
available excessiveness than that of the
baseline however
this marker showed a better expression
by using the commercially available xfm
the expression of cd62l
and pd1 was the same by using prime
xv
t cell cdn
and the commercially available xfm
you might ask
a question regarding the low expression
of cd25 market in all the groups of the
g-lx system here right
i should say
this data and direct system are from day
14 at the point the vast majority of
cells are in the resting state and do
not express the activation marker
whereas the quantum data they are from
day nine
so we still see some cd25 expression as
the seller is still experiencing the
effects of
anti cd3 cd25 cd
28 t cell activation b
in addition the activation beats in the
case of the quantum experiment can't
leave the closed circuit the closed
system
whereas the activation antibodies in
g-rex's are
you know actually completely removed
during the media exchange
step
as you can see in this slide glx system
the prime xv t cell cdm
increased the percentage of cd8
positivity cells however the increase
was slightly less than what happened by
using the commercially available xsfm
and also rpmi plus 10 percent fps
in the quantum bi reactor
as you can see here the prime xp t cell
cdm increase the percentage of cd8
positive t cells
here better than those of
g-reg system furthermore the increase of
cd8-positive t-cells while using the
prime
x-v-t cell cdm in the quantum bi reactor
was more than that of the commercially
available excess fm so
we might say that the prime xp t cell
cdm showed its
the best effect on increasing the
percentage of cd8 positive t cell when
it's used in the quantum bi reactors
so cell diameter analysis since a
shorter process turnaround for the prime
x v t cell cbm
in comparison to the commercially
available xfm medium in the quantum
bioreactor
at the conclusion of this study
i
will say that
prime xvt cell cdn supports t cell
expansion without additional serum under
chemically defined condition this medium
is capable of supporting t cell
expansion
across
aesthetic and dynamic cultivation
conditions
this medium supports expansion of both
cd4 positive t cells and cd8 positive t
cells but it favors cd8 positive t cells
and it maintains functionality of this
at the end i should thank anastadiya
silikova
supriya pokali and chandana sharma for
their contribution and support for
the chemically defined media related
innovative projects in fujifilm vermont
scientific in recent years and also
preparing this presentation
thank you very much for your attention i
take the question
thank you dr shahabi for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar i want to remind our audience if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
all right let's get started
our first question here asks
does using chemically defined media
require supplementation
thank you very much again
so
actually yes
you know
using chemical defined media requires
supplementation there are some general
supplementations for example some
hormones for example insulin is gonna be
needed for a lot of cells are you gonna
say
you know essential amino acids or other
things but there are some
specific uh sample of supplementation
that they are needed for a specific cell
so the question is going to
however we're going to say that short
answer is yes it needs supplementation
great thank you our next question here
is a two-part question and this one asks
do you have any experience using
recombinant
human aluminum
albumin excuse me um rha and second part
here what are your thoughts on moving
from bsa slash hsa to rha
so the
the first part i should say yes as you
can see there you know the cdm
media all of them they've got
recombinant
uh
albumin i mean uh human
all moving and
so if you're gonna have a cdm or are you
gonna say chemical defined media you
need to use rhsa and you cannot use for
example bsa
and our experiments show that generally
speaking i'm gonna say
they work very well i mean recombinant
hsa in comparison to
you know plasma drive
uh i'll be i mean i'm gonna say so human
or animal resources generally speaking
sometimes even better but there are some
suppliers we saw that you know the fkc
efficacy is not good so i cannot mention
these suppliers here but there are some
suppliers so when you got something you
should actually you know make a
comparison between what you got or
recombinant hsa and you know the plasma
derived hsa you should compare it at
first and after that you can move
forward
great thank you
all right next question here
what experience have you had
oh excuse me sorry about that
what experience have you had with cdm in
converting anchorage cells to suspension
cells
so
actually yes we got some experience here
and you know actually
but not regarding cell traffic actually
here but other areas yes we got some
experience and
um
i i can't say yes we can use cdm's for
you know this purpose too you know for
actually
converting uh
the anchory cells to suspension
so yeah we can use it
great all right next question here asks
do cells need to go through a period of
adoption when they expand in chemical
defined media
oh yes absolutely they do need
you know to go through the abduct
adaptation period so and there are some
you know actually different ways and
methods for the adaptation
so yeah and they do need
great
next question here asks how can you
protect against sheer stress and ph
changes
so actually as mentioned in this slide's
theorem itself got a pretty big effect
against of shear stress and also psa for
shira says
uh the effects of serum is gonna be more
you know because of its viscosity some
studies they show this is related to
albion and other studies show now is not
related to all women so we cannot say
anything definite so
i can say for chemical defined media is
you know we can use polaronic at 68 for
example of course other surfactant but
one of the most used exploring
you know surfactant we can use it if
it's needed because you know shear
stress is not a general and universal
problem when you got
you know
you know ordinary cell culture the shear
stress is not you know actually
a very big problem but where you're
gonna go toward dynamic cell cultures i
mean for example
uh quantum bioreactors
so or you've got a lot of agitations
enduring to your cell culture for any
purpose as you can
you should deal with it as i've
mentioned you can use we can use
plaronic so fractions for example
peronic f68
great and i want to thank our audience
for these great questions that are
coming in here i want to continue to
encourage you to submit these questions
we've got plenty of time here and would
love to answer them so let's keep moving
here number
uh this next one how important is it to
choose right vessels for cdm conditions
uh you know actually
cdm
i gonna say cdn media industry is too
young
but
as i mentioned chemical defined media is
going to be specific so
we think is not going to be a specific
just for the cell type so it's going to
be a specific for vessel types maybe
so all the time that we produce the cdn
media here we
actually
use different vessels to
make sure
that
it's going to be compatible with
different vessels so generally speaking
i'm going to say maybe you know in the
future yes we we find something else
that no it's chemical defined media is
gonna like you know some um containing
media as is good for
different uh vessels but i'm gonna say
we should take a look at the you know
scales of the vessels and also the
dynamic as well for example
is it is this plate or flask or also or
is it gtx or no is it
for for example quantum bioreactor is a
dynamic system so here we try to
try different vessels to make sure so at
this point i'm gonna say yeah
so it's better that you know you got a
cdm i mean chemical defined media that
have been tested for different vessels
maybe
it needs to be customized for different
vessels so that's the knowledge that we
got now as i told you as i mentioned
because it's a very
young
you know industry actually maybe in the
future we find okay no
you don't need to to be worried about
the vessels but at this point
regarding the type of ourselves the
dynamic the scheduled material the
volume of vessels is better to be tested
wonderful
all right i have another question for
you here this one asks do cells perform
differently in prime xv t cell cdm when
compared to serum contain media
oh actually
no
uh
you know actually
they are the same and or we got some
feedback from our customers that you
know even some in some you know occasion
this media actually acts and perform
even better than
uh you know serum containing media so
are you gonna say no it's gonna be you
know i can
you know behave in the same way
great thank you
all right well thank you again dr
shahabi for your time today in your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor fujifilm
irvine scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrints will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye
thank you very much bye
you